Really below the surface like that.
People don't know what's behind the curtain.
Yeah,
no one knows about it.
And they've got like these devastating injuries that they're fighting off.
And then competing against world class fighters with injuries.
He's torn ligaments and talking about Tony Ferguson,
he's like,
it doesn't look comfortable on that leg.
No,
I mean,
he was like,
yeah,
it wasn't.
You know what?
He went six months from catastrophic knee injury where the bone literally
separated from the ligament.
The ligament tore off the bar.
You ever see the,
the,
the picture of his surgery?
Oh Jamie,
shut up.
Shut up.
Pull that shit up Jane.
It's a crazy surgery because it's,
I'm not exaggerating,
it might be a 12 inch scar.
It's enormous.
It's like that big and it's all jagged and shit and it's just,
he ripped it apart.
They had an open amount of 12 months,
not even six months.
Six months.
I mean,
yeah.
Insane.
I don't understand how that,
that guy doesn't clearly get the title shot.
He does.
We should talk about that.
Look at that.
Wow,
that's crazy.
And the thing is that was just from a trip he just tripped was fucking bananas.
Yeah.
What's the second image,
Jeremy?
Oh,
the other side way worse angle.
Yeah.
The um,
the extent of that injury,
the fact that he came back in six months and what's really interesting is he
came back in six months.
He didn't spar apparently really need to talk to him about this and I'm gonna
have him on with Eddie.
Um,
he didn't spar.
He just prepared.
Prepared.
Yeah.
He's one of Eddie's black belts.
Wow.
Really?
Yeah.
He's a black belt.
He should be.
I think he is.
I'm pretty sure it's fine.
I'm fine.
I'm pretty sure Eddie gave him his black belt after he submitted Kevin Lee.
He did.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
He's uh,
he's 10th Planet Guy.
Wow.
That's pretty cool.
It's pretty bad ass.
He's got a nasty Darce choke probably.
He should clearly get the title shot.
It doesn't make sense to me.
Even that when he came back,
he shouldn't have even gotten stripped.
In hindsight,
I agree 100% and then it's like you have a copy of it.
Who is the title holder fair and square I guess.
But like you never beat the champion.
Well,
he's more of a legit title holder in my opinion,
than could be bros before Connor because he didn't ally Quinta who wasn't even
supposed to be fighting for the title.
Whereas Kevin Lee is a way more like Ferguson got it from,
well Ferguson,
Fuck Kevin Lee,
right.
For the interim title because Connor left it.
But Kevin Lee prepared for Tony Ferguson.
They met,
they fought for the interim title and Kevin Lee is like a top contender.
Right?
He's a fucking tough guy.
Obviously he went five rounds.
It could be Connor couldn't go five rounds with could be,
and he,
you know,
he put up resistance.
It was,
it was a good fight.
He would never make anyone a title shot.
No.
Maybe in the same chat discussion.
Well,
he's fighting Kevin Lee.
If he beats Kevin Lee,
he,
that's the next cat look.
Ally Quinta is fucking legit.
He's very legit.
He's underrated.
Really underrated in my opinion.
I think he's the way he got up from Khabib,
taken him down.
Nobody's able to do that.
He got up,
like pretty consistently,
took very little damage on the ground.
Wasn't,
wasn't Kebede,
was never able to pound him out the way he pounded out.
Connor,
if you go back and watch ally Quinta versus Khabib and Connor versus could be,
you realize how fucking good ally Quinta is just of,
there's nothing on the ground.
Well,
he didn't in that fight
really.
That's when Mendez took them down a two weeks notice and it was like if he
didn't,
Gas Mendez would have beat him.
It's true.
It's like he can't fight them.
Well,
um,
he did very well in the ground and gets Max Holloway,
which was early in Max's career.
Max was only like 21 at the time.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
I agree with you.
That's definitely his weakest part of his game and the strongest part of
Khabib's game.
My point was just that ally Quinta did not get beat up on the ground like that
did not get close to being stopped,
went full five rounds and could be clearly won the fight.
But Alec went to provided resistance and provided more of a struggle than Conor
did.
I want to say thanks to some of the reasons it's holding La Quinta back from the
fans,
being from them,
thinking of him as like a top is his name.
It's just not,
he has a name of someone who would be like in the early round of Mike Tyson's
punch out.
You say that,
but
if you started starching world champions,
nobody would give a fuck.